Okay, we just signed up for a lot.
We have so many things to teach them.
What should we cover?
>> Hold that thought, I need something.
>> Where are you going?
>> Here, this is for you.
>> Thank you.
>> Let's just pour out some beans.
>> What are you doing?
>> Well these are not our bean but
let's imagine they are for a second.
>> Okay.
I just want to create a little
coffee trail which is going to
be a symbol of the journey our
students will take with us.
>> Okay, I like that.
>> So let's just say this is our student
and this is where we are beginning.
>> Oh, and this can be where they end.
>> Right, which is where they
are an Android developer, right?
And we're focusing on just this
part of our course right now, so
this is where we are.
So I'm just going to clean it out and
zoom in into the main
part of the course.
Okay, well, let's say there are three
big lessons in this course.
>> Only three?
>> Let's say there are three for
now, yeah?
>> Okay.
>> So, this is lesson one,
two, and three.
Let's talk about lesson one.
I'm just going to zoom in there and
clean up the dust,yeah.
Well, I'm going to split this
further into three sections, and
you might guess what my favorite
number is at this point.
Which is?
>> Two.
>> Three.
>> [LAUGH] Okay.
>> [LAUGH] What is the first
thing we should do in lesson one?
>> I think they should
learn about views.
>> Oh, views, things that you see
on the phone, so like a check box,
a radio button, an image,
a text of some sort.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> So we introduce them to that here.
In the second part of lesson one-
>> Then they can learn to
customize those views.
>> Oh, okay, so you're changing
the color of a font or size on an image.
>> Exactly.
Then this part three, we should teach
them how to position views on a screen.
>> So it's like bottom left or top right
or where is it going on the font screen.
>> Yeah.
>> Good, so
let's begin at the beginning.
>> The first thing in Android you need
to know is something called views.
>> Views.